Cuál es la función de este tipo de
drones Y por qué razones podría caer en
un vuelo descontrolado que lo lleve a
estrellarse como lo Afirma Rusia
el objetivo de este tipo de drone es
obtener información todo el mundo habla
de los millones de dólares que Estados
Unidos le ha dado a Ucrania y la otan en
términos generales y hablan de la de los
armamentos y en muchas ocasiones olvidan
el apoyo de inteligencia este drone se
encarga de ese aspecto de recopilar
inteligencia de distintos movimientos
dentro del mar Negro en este caso en
particular muy improbable de que se haya
ido en un patrón de vuelo de controlado
ya que estos estos drones están muy bien
controlados y habrá que esperar a que se
hagan público si se hace pública de
alguna manera información adicional
sobre el la colisión que informa hoy
Washington viendo este panorama se
pueden esperar más sanciones de
Washington a Moscú
hemos visto ya que se han tomado pasos
diplomáticos en el frente diplomático
como muy bien reportaron hace unos
minutos llamaron al al representante
diplomático de moco en Washington y le y
le hicieron verdad un reclamo a nivel
diplomático lo mismo ocurrió en en Moscú
No creo que en este momento haya otros
otras acciones otros pasos por los
ejemplos a nivel militar creo que se
tratarán de utilizar otros elementos de
los instrumentos de poder que tiene
Estados Unidos pero sin duda la
situación pues trae una atención
adicional entre Rusia Estados Unidos con
telón de fondo la Guerra de Ucrania
justamente le pregunto por este hecho
porque este choque entre las partes
podría de alguna manera influir en la
guerra
el hecho de que este drone estuviera
allí como dije anteriormente parte del
apoyo en la recolección de inteligencia
en apoyo al ejército ucraniano hay que
ver Yo creo que es muy temprano no creo
yo que vaya a ocurrir algo en términos
de que vayan a moverse tropas de Estados
Unidos
yo creo que la reacción de Estados
Unidos va a ser enviar otro otro dron y
inmediatamente ya con mucha probabilidad
está en el aire y y continuar el apoyo
para enviar de esa manera el mensaje de
que no van a ser intimidados y que van a
continuar en aguas internacionales
apoyando Ucrania yo creo que eso es lo
que vamos a ver y tendríamos que ver
entonces si o vuelve a ocurrir Cómo
sería la reacción de Washington